previously on TV sins it's maximus
renegade star soldier that man is
playing Galaga thought we wouldn't
notice but we did so with a shot of
space cliche a lot of space and time
look like someone stole footage of my
colonoscopy and Photoshop the TARDIS
inside my black hole the TARDIS
conversation many who viens have had
with their better halves makes it into
this episode what do you think Donna
would be out of this world of TV since
you mean ghost that's a good question
there are so many theories I'm what
transpired on the island maybe they were
dead all along but that brings up more
questions that had answers maybe Locke
was actually the devil and oh he was
talking about rose she is are these
people insane
she vanished what is the scene doctor
who proves once again the show is
comprised of 92% rapid-fire questions
while the doctor runs around looking
confused
are you trying to catch the traitor you
know stupid Martian is gonna stop me
from getting married how are you I'm I'm
not I'm not I'm not from Mars motion is
like calling also does cope and it's
just a suitable
[Music]
no one will be seated during the Ober
suspenseful six different taxis refused
to pick up our protagonist portion of
the Christmas special first that's
drunkest and second the good doctor was
also participating in that hail fail
trail so why weren't they stopping for
him either this driver had time to see
her from a distance through cross
traffic roll his window all the way down
coordinate what to say with his mate in
the passenger seat and yell it out the
window all before even passing her
either the show is stretching reality
for a lame expositional joke or he's
actually another Time Lord and his
TARDIS is a blue Suzuki Ignace Christmas
this is a fair question since there has
been very little Christmasy about this
Christmas special I would argue diehard
is more of a Christmas special than this
is so far these fake Santa's take their
sweet time proceeding with the intended
brass weapon just so the doctor can run
a throw money to the masses who all
happen to be paying attention cliche
before we need the campus considering
this is roughly the 900th time
Donna's mentioned this and the first 12
minutes of this episode I don't believe
she thinks we do also these Santa's eyes
keep changing from solid with the pupil
to gauzy without one which makes sense
if you have to have a mass with
see-through eyes for an actual driver
but doesn't make sense for well reality
ah geez Donna shut your mouth before kid
hears you each parent should get to
decide when it's time for their own kids
to know about mechanical Santa wait so
like all of traffic is still going at
the same speed on this Highway even
though everyone behind them can clearly
see there's a floating goddamn police
box going down the road seems like that
should have been the move he started
with I'm not sure how many sci-fi shows
or movies have used the kids watching
something magical happen while the
adults miss a truck but it's probably
just shy of all of them with this ring I
thee by oh damn using bling to buy Oh
damp the ladies is so 2006 come on then
robot Santa's what are they for they're
trying to blend in I'm at the last
Christmas whose position great big
spaceship hovering over London you
didn't notice finds a bit of hangover
sure but it is the kind of thing you see
on the news or hear from a friend
shortly after the hangover subsides
right stop late pay me something I
continue to say to the senator somehow
makes it into the [ __ ] script oh it's
quite big reception all plans
everyone's gonna be heartbroken funny
joke and all but there is a long
emotional journey from thinking she
might be dead to having a party
especially considering they saw her
disappear even after her mom got her
message I'm just not buying it every
single person in this room is staring at
her and no one sees this show that's
time for this why exactly are they still
trying to pull this charade off they
would stand out less if they were just
walking around as robots this creepy
Santa getup brings way more attention to
them holy did they just paint over a
GameCube controller wrong he's got the
blue show and he's not afraid to use it
damn these things must be as dangerous
as the weather in the November rain
video if you're attacking a man with a
sonic screwdriver sure that screwdriver
is the screwiest weapon of convenient
powers since the wand from a Harry
Potter movie let's bury Olmos [ __ ]
Torchwood Institute Mary thy side man
evasion his guise of London fulla Daleks
always his spine she doesn't have any
clue who Torchwood is or the events he's
talking about and how would she know she
was in Spain when an event she didn't
know occurred happen inside amok
strangely enough pencil inside a mug is
exactly what my college girlfriend
compared me to when a 3d graphical
representation of that building that was
done using CorelDraw from 1992 you tell
me these buildings got a secret floor
not sure how secret it is if the lower
basement is listed on an elevator button
maybe I should go to the police this
certainly seems like something one of
the hundreds of wedding attendees might
have done already don't you think the
fact that there aren't already bobbies
all over this episode is mad as a bag of
ferrets Segway Segway zags way too long
particle extrusion and yet this active
super secret lab is completely abandoned
today by its staff I guess they're very
serious about their holiday scheduling
synchronized intimidation is very
cinematic but from a practical
standpoint there is no reason these
discount Cybermen wouldn't already be
aiming at their targets I don't think so
hi
on Christmas night this ancient alien
species cares enough to be aware of this
puny planets various holidays and that
must come from the dark times busy to
these eco billions they were carnivores
omnivores like devoured whole planets
sometimes I wonder if instead of calling
the doctors partners companions they
should have gone with convenient
expositional delivery receptacles
probably just too wordy technically
every baby is born hungry so if you
choose to use that hunger to eat people
and planets then yes but is most
definitely your fault you shouldn't even
exist
Disney live-action sequels this
double-cross makes no sense why did
Lance even need to do the sprinting acts
ruse there are a million more convenient
ways to set up a cruel reveal if that's
what your end goal is really because
I've seen enough of him in this episode
I know he's not who's all there in the
job title the head of human resources
this time its personnel will handle
they're not that witty Barb's Sir
Lancelot and then I'll start with a
woman who thinks the heights of
excitement she's a new flavor Pringle oh
well were there mister I'm not here
anymore speaking ill of parmesan and
roasted garlic Pringles I'm delicious
Oh ladies don't out if that's the case
you've done about this in all the wrong
ways
why have mysterious Santa robots hunt
her down at kidnap her when the man she
loves and trusts could have just walked
her down here himself is it because you
needed the show to last an hour I think
it's because you needed the show to last
an hour who under factors picked for
Doctor Who villains are sourced from
local over actors anonymous groups
because damn in case you're having
trouble understanding her broken
recognizing glitch let me translate she
said remember all those rules we
expositor earlier well here are some
random words that negate them so the
plot keep plot you don't say yeah but
making Lance a key was kind of a
last-second Hail Mary so I'm not sure
exactly how this was ever part of spider
lady's plan quite impolite to your lady
friend
the Empress does not a true
good to know that this being you know
the one that's maniacally laughing about
eating an entire planet has a bowl Cup
once a gun deadly stuff neglects to
actually deadly this works he certainly
does
even with old school effects cheesy
dialogue and force plot mechanics I
continue to somehow have a great time
there's a reason this show has been
around since 1963 it's damn fun behind
take your sin back no it keeps no wings
and no wings and no wing wait so the
doctor just opened part of the Thames
River to float down the hole that
reaches to the core of the earth which
is currently empty in the river and
doing some crazy to the earth school
isn't everyone good thing that Tim's was
so shallow then and also apparently
devoid of life
I miss my wedding lost my job and became
a widow on the same day also known as
the circle of life I couldn't save him
he deserved it no I did he did you ain't
Christmas yes I do even if it's smooth
good thing I had the atmospheric exciter
button installed right by the door for
just such a convenient occasion then
isn't it well you could come with me
unless of course the audience loved me
so much that they demand my return then
I'll change my mind because you know
reasons
it's a little tight around your web
shooter mutation it is the key to our
evolution it has enabled us to evolve
from a single-celled organism into the
dominant species on the planet excuse me
no no I'm not no i won't i won't i will
not open that door please go to the
extraction point easy do you trust me